so I want to give you a horror story
about selling so when I got out of the
army the military I was accustomed to
everybody screaming hey you got to get
this do your push-ups all right Run 10
laps go do this I'm like oh my God
intense so I got into sales at Bally's
and people trying to get in shape and
I've tried to sell the same way fail
miserably do you realize after a month
and a half of being in sales I was this
close of just saying this isn't for me
I'm going to go back in the military and
stay in for 20 years but once I found
out my selling style I started selling
at Fox Hills Mall saw which style fit my
personality the rest is history I've
been to sales business now for 22 23
years and my life has dramatically
changed because I learned my selling
style if you don't know your selling
style click on the link above or below
we'll take the quiz and learn exactly
what selling style fits your personality